[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm a roboticist and I get two types
of reactions from people when I talk
about AI and robotics some people get
really nervous ask about cyber Skynet
and then ask me when the robots will
take over their jobs and there is the
other group who gets very excited than
who says well when will I be able to
offload even more to machines now I
believe that everyone stands to benefit
from AI but we have to listen to the
fears of that first group we have to
provide solutions and we have to provide
different perspectives for how to see
things differently and that starts with
understanding that AI is just a tool and
like any other tool it isn't inherently
good or bad it is what we choose to do
with it and I happen to believe that we
can choose to make to do some incredible
things and let me start with an example
so this week I published a paper about a
new algorithm that has all sorts of
interesting theoretical properties and
essentially this algorithm matches
supply and demand and it can do so in
real-time for thousands of jobs we
implemented this algorithm on the
publicly available taxi data set for New
York City and we showed that 3000
capacity for cars that do ride-sharing
and trip pooling can meet the demand
that is currently serviced by 14,000
taxis in New York City they can meet 98%
of this demand within a guaranteed trip
delay of a maximum of three point five
minutes so the journal is smooth we
wanted to ask one question does this
mean that 10,000 jobs go away and my
perspective is that it really depends
how we look at this problem so we can
provide a new perspective with a new
business model where we say that if taxi
drivers agree to join the system in
other words they stop being independent
agents and they do what the system tells
them to do and customers agree
to share rides then we can get 10,000
cars of roads we can provide drivers
with shorter shifts for the same amount
of income and we achieve better traffic
lower pollution improve quality of life
for all plus we create new jobs because
getting these systems deployed
maintained and operated will create new
jobs but in the future taxes could
become autonomous and so this will
change the job landscape however we have
some time because level for autonomy is
actually not ready for private and I'm
sorry for public roads but level for
autonomy is ready for lower complexity
private roads like the one you see in
this video which was done in Singapore
so the technology for autonomous driving
in these lower types of complexity
environments could have immediate social
benefits for example this technology on
private waste could give Bob a much
higher quality of life in his retirement
say Bob wants to go to feed the fish
who's his friend Alice to do so Bob
brings up his you got wheels interface
fix the type of vehicle that suits him
today it may be a golf cart vehicle
tomorrow maybe a shopping cart and when
the robot arrives Bob gets a call he
heads out and then he's off together
with Alice to feed the fish
so although although this robot car has
no driver we should not consider that it
displaced his work because the system
does not exist at the moment however we
can imagine all the different jobs that
will be involved in the manufacturing
deploying maintaining and serving this
kind of new approach to autonomous
mobility all this while giving Bob a
much higher quality of life
so today personal mobility could include
systems like the golf cart I showed you
it
also include other types of vehicles
like these kinds of scooters wheelchairs
and many many other vehicles and you can
begin to imagine the applications that
would be enabled by such fleets now the
same technology for autonomous driving
can be mapped on to wearable devices to
provide safe navigation to blind and
visually impaired users which at the
moment does not exist at the moment in
today's technological age blind and
visually impaired users still walk
around with a walking stick so what can
we do well we can map the perception
system of a self-driving car onto a
laser belt and some cameras and with
this the system is able to identify the
world and even describe it in words that
get projected onto a Braille buckle for
the blind users so for instance this
technology could describe a fabulous
window display or the presence of an
obstacle behind or say hello to a friend
Alice who is passing by or hears a cat
so in fact this technology is really not
that far off and here is an example of
using this technology with our blind
user that is truly able to navigate the
world going up and down the stairs
moving safely say to the bus stop and
once the bus arrives moving to an empty
seat on the bus and at the moment this
is simply not possible and it's a huge
challenge for for blind people just
close your eyes and imagine what it
would take for you to find an empty seat
in this room without the use of your
perception system so these are some of
the amazing things that technology can
do to improve quality of life to improve
efficiency to provide better access by
taking advantage of our state-of-the-art
in autonomy for motion and in addition
to these great individual benefits
all of these systems are novel so
producing them will create new jobs now
in addition to autonomy in motion we
also see tremendous progress in how much
information machines can process and I
call this autonomy at rest and medicine
is a great example machines today can
look at more radiology scans than
radiologists would see in a lifetime and
in a recent study an AI system was asked
to look at lymph node cells and classify
them as cancerous or not cancerous the
AI system made 7.5 percent error as
compared to the human error of 3.5%
but when working together the human and
the Machine achieved 0.5% error much
better than each one separately so
machines working together with people
have tremendous ability to make an
impact
now today these systems are primarily
available in advanced cancer centers but
imagined deploying them everywhere
imagine giving doctors in rural areas
access to this kind of tool and then
augmenting with the latest and greatest
in natural language understanding that
will enable doctors to access the latest
clinical trials relevant to the patient
they're considering now even without
having studied those trials yet another
case study is for lawyers
so machines and humans working together
can be better lawyers and today we
already have seen a revolution in the
job of a lawyer
due to word processing internet and
email that have completely changed how
lawyers draft documents access
information and share information in the
next wave of tools in natural language
processing promised an equally profound
impact on the job of a lawyer with
natural language understanding systems
machines could predict a decision
machines could examine thousands of
pages of prior cases and provide the
most relevant information to lawyers but
machines cannot be lawyers because
machines will not be able to counsel a
client they will not be able to persuade
the judge and they will not be able to
write a compelling argument at least not
yet
so machines cannot be lawyers but they
can change the nature of jobs lawyers do
and the same principles apply to many
other professions for example teachers
today teachers spend 1/5 of their time
grading with the use of natural language
processing they can spend a little less
time grading and a little bit more time
with students now advances in autonomy
in motion and autonomy at rest also will
impact production and we all assume that
robots and AI will lead to fewer
manufacturing jobs but what if they lead
to better jobs and even more jobs
what if robots and software could allow
people very fine-grain control over what
manufacturing lines look like this is a
really challenging problem today
reconfiguring a manufacturing line takes
a very long time and for that reason
most manufacturing processes are for
most assembly lines are configured for
products that are in existence for years
but what if you put very quickly
reconfigure manufacturing lines well
then we we will really enable mass
customization so robots have already
enabled mass production and I believe
that robots plus computation will enable
mass customization and this could mean
this could meet the rising demand of
demikhov of customization and
personalization in just about everything
we buy and in fact today we do not have
the ability to keep up with this demand
at a price point that most people can
afford and because of that we are forced
to
use fixed prod products mostly offshore
and these products get distributed in
big shops but by teaming AI robots and
people together we can reshape the world
of manufacturing we can imagine a world
where experts design templated products
that get instantiated by people at home
and get produced locally in smaller
factories that are closer to population
centers this could revolutionize
production it could revolutionize
manufacturing it could bring a lot of
manufacturing jobs back so when you look
at all the positives of what AI can do
with deductive and they are driven
reasoning with personalization
customization the democratization for
predicting improving and adapting you
can begin to imagine a potential impact
in so many different industries but it's
worth noting that there aren't that
today's AI has significant limitations
and in fact in mark zuckerberg words
most of what ai systems do today are
variants of the same fundamental pattern
recognition techniques and when we
recognize an object we are not able to
go beyond that we are not able to
recognize actions and activities and
behaviors so there are significant
challenges and even with a major
advances being made today artificial
intelligence is nowhere near close to
people in perceiving reasoning
communicating and in creativity most of
the machine learning tools we have today
are one-off solutions that are only
usable by experts and I'm not saying
computer science experts it's machine
learning experts and then there are a
lot of important facts about the state
of technology so crunching large data
sets does not translate into knowledge
and making complex calculations does not
produce autonomy also the achieving
really high a really high
percentage of correctness 99.99% correct
which is what you need in self-driving
is exponentially harder than achieving
say 90% correct and perception and
action is much harder than perception
which is harder than crunching data now
all of this suggests that today's AI
limitations hold it back from out
sinking humanity and this table shows
four categories of jobs for rough
categories of jobs according to skills
and qualifications AI systems are not
ready for the first for the jobs that
fall in the first row and robots will
struggle with the jobs that fall in the
last row because a robot that can do
welding will be hopeless in forestry or
in construction so AI can achieve some
automation for the middle level jobs but
even the most vulnerable jobs that fall
in those middle categories like
accounting even these types of jobs
involve significant social interactions
that are difficult to automate so
altogether this suggests that we should
we should look at tasks not professions
and this chart shows you a graph that
was done by McKinsey here you see a
number of professions and in color you
see the technological readiness for the
different types of tasks people do in
those Patel profile professions so
people manage others they apply
expertise they do unpredictable or
predictable physical work and they do
data processing the targets for
automation are in green and in blue and
the size of the bubble shows how much
time a person spends doing that type of
task so it's kind of exciting to think
about AI making everyone's job better by
taking away the repetitive and
uninteresting aspects of the job but
it's much easier to think about which
tasks might be automated than to imagine
the new kinds of jobs that will be
created and so for instance in the 20th
century agricultural employment dropped
from 40 percent to 2 percent and perhaps
a farsighted specialist in the 19th
century could have predicted this but
only two decades ago we had the big
dot-com boom and nobody predicted all
these different types of jobs that now
provide so much employment so I'm very
excited and optimistic about AI but I do
have two causes for concern they do not
concern the number of jobs but the first
one is about the quality of jobs and
wages so sometimes the a and sometimes
AI opens the field to more people to
join a job so for instance GPS made it
so that taxi drivers did not have to
memorize maps that opens the field to
more people who could become taxi
drivers and put the wages down push the
wages down and Eric already showed your
chart like this that predicts the drop
in in the middle level jobs so the only
so in my opinion the only way to
mitigate this part polarization is
education and I'd like to observe that
we can imagine short term and long term
solutions in particular for short term
solutions I would like to highlight
bitsource which is a new startup in
Kentucky so big source trains coal
miners to be data miners and guess what
coal miners are not upset about their
old jobs and there are very excited
about the new jobs and the new
opportunities and so the question is how
can we take this model and and
incentivize other industries and other
places to do to do similar programs I
think this will be a great solution for
the short term now in the long term I
think we really have to embrace the idea
that computational thinking is the
fourth pillar for
literacy in the 21st century and to to
introduce mandatory computer science
training from from early age from
kindergarten from first grade I can
imagine that in 2025 the high school
graduates will be equipped with the IT
tools that will allow them to to do this
and I would observe that China South
Korea Japan UK 12 European countries all
have implemented have embraced the idea
of mandatory computer science training
I'm sure that the US will follow and
then we will have great benefits by 2025
now my second cause for concern is what
I call anti intellectualism in our
country and the dumbing down of our
country the the lack of trust and
respect in science and this is something
that we should concern all of us and we
should really ask ourselves what kind of
world do we want to live in now I
believe that technology can be a huge
vector for positive change so how do we
have to step it up to actually change
the world and have people at large have
the public embrace science technology
embrace all these ideas education is one
way but I think we also need to change
how we communicate about AI we need to
inspire people to dream about how their
lives can be better with AI rather than
experiencing fear because of AI and it's
on us to do that so in conclusion I
would say that in one important sense
machines and people are quite similar to
each other in that they can help us or
hurt us depending on the choices we make
we can't stop technology from improving
and changing the world but we can be
proactive and we could think about the
consequences we could think about what
we need to do to ensure that those
changes are for the better I think Eric
Aldous mindfulness with respect to
change so computers and much
Jeanne's do not need to be competitors
especially when they do so much better
working together but to get here we
really need to invest in developing the
field of AI we need to develop the
science of autonomy and the science of
intelligence we need to think broadly
about computer science and computational
thinking as part of literacy and we need
to change how we message about AI to
help people dream rather than get them
scared thank you
[Music]